a third thing a third reason you might
want to employ a computer-based decision
support system is you want high
consistency now I don't mean consistency
as in like is it thick or is it
consistent as it consistency as it's
going to be the same all the time right
it's predictable so I want a system that
makes the same choices repeatedly
now can you only think of an example why
I might want this or where this might be
a problem if it wasn't consistent you
thought yeah
good good okay excellent okay let's go
with that okay so what you've got people
making decisions you have some big
problems right don't you
thinking about the kinds of decisions
you might suppose you want to get a loan
okay so the bank manager is going to be
the person making a decision about
number one whether you can get a loan
number two how much of a loan you can
get okay
now wouldn't it suck if the decision
that the bank manager made for you right
depended on what kind of a day that bank
manager was having whether he'd had
lunch or not has kids are behaving last
night
you know just if he's in a you know
grumpy sort of moon just if he
personally is just generally a pessimist
and doesn't like people you know or
something like that okay now can you see
the problem you have different people
different circumstances and they change
the decisions but that's not good for a
company that's terrible and for us as
consumers that's also terrible so if we
want consistency okay machines are more
consistent than humans our machines are
more consistent in agreement we can
program them we can get them to follow a
set of rules and always apply the same
kinds of things like if I've got ten
people who have the same earning power
same amount of savings basic same
socioeconomic status then we should give
them the same amount of life okay but if
you let that ride completely on people
in their subjective decisions there
won't be consistency or they'll be less
at least does that make sense okay
now I want more like I said this is not
exhaustive okay but it's it's I think
it's the main reason we said lots of
computation lots of data consistency
lastly when you need to make choices and
you need to make them fast
so when speed is of the essence
computers are really helpful okay
particularly the situation is
complicated yeah for a lot of the
decisions we think about okay time is
not really that big a deal okay so for
instance
um let's go without chopping okay on a
week-to-week basis no big deal okay you
can you can take plenty of time you can
you plan our weeks in advance you don't
have to make that decision you know
straight away you're not under time
pressure really okay
even you know these big decisions here
as you get up the time pressure sort of
decreases because you've got more time
to think about right however there are
some events that happen very very seldom
but they require very very quick
decision-making can anyone think of
something
I'm gonna say no number one because when
they sales happen basically secondly
because usually think you know it's like
you get some time to think about them
right and what's that what's the problem
like if you if you don't make a decision
quickly then oh no I miss them 25% off
you know you'll survive there will be
another sale matching cards right what
other shuttle movements require rapid
decision I'm gonna take the best part of
your answer which was just one word and
I'm gonna push you that you think you
think what's going on here
natural disasters right fires
earthquakes floods typhoons threatening
million dollar bills that are lying
around and before okay these things
happen very often right not very often
at least we heard more that often okay
but making decisions related to them you
gotta jump fast okay what kind of
decisions means you have to make this is
disaster relief thinking okay what kind
of decisions
okay firstly where where do I am when is
where should I send help I can't wish
that send help maybe sending it to the
location of the typhoon adult not such a
great idea okay but like surrounded
areas which one's gonna be much needed
okay not just where should I go
but what should I send right do I send
people do I send do I send a robot that
can disarm a bomb do
send food do I send medical supplies
what do I send okay all right
where what you know when depending on
the kind of disaster right you might
want to wait some kind of interval or
send people in on in waves okay now all
these choices you've got you can't just
sit around waiting right minutes the
timescale we're talking about even
though these things happen not very
quickly right I'm not very often so
therefore if we want to make these
decisions quickly
fire spreading what are you going to do
okay we use decision support systems to
help us predict what are going to be the
most effective places to send crews okay